[Music]
with all the legitimate concerns about
AIDS and avian flu and we'll hear about
that from the brilliant doctor brilliant
later today I want to talk about the
other pandemic which is cardiovascular
disease diabetes hypertension all of
which are completely preventable for at
least 95 for seven people just by
changing diet and lifestyle and what's
happening is that there's a
globalization of illness occurring that
people are starting to eat like us and
live like us and die like us and in one
generation for example age has gone from
having one of the lowest rates of heart
disease and obesity and diabetes to one
of the highest and in Africa
cardiovascular disease equals the HIV
and AIDS deaths in most countries so
there's a critical window of opportunity
we have to make an important difference
that can affect the lives of literally
millions of people and practice
preventive medicine on a global scale
harden blood vessel disease is still
kill more people not only in this
country but also worldwide then
everything else combined and yet it's
completely preventable for almost
everybody it's not only preventable it's
actually reversible in for the last
almost 29 years we've been able to show
that by simply changing diet and
lifestyle using these very high-tech
expensive state-of-the-art measures to
prove how powerful these very simple and
low tech and low cost interventions can
be like quantitative arteriography
before and after a year and cardiac PET
scans we showed a few months ago we
published the first studies showing that
you can actually stop or reverse the
progression of prostate cancer by making
changes in diet and lifestyle and 70%
regression and the tumor growth were
inhibition of the tumor growth compared
to only 9% in the control group and in
the MRI in the amarte spectroscopy here
that's prostate tumor activities shown
in red you can see it diminishing after
a year now there is an epidemic of
obesity two-thirds of adults and 15% of
kids what's really concerning to me is
that diabetes has increased 70% in the
past ten years and this may be the first
generation which our kids live a shorter
life span than we do that's pitiful and
it's preventable now these are not
election returns these are the
people the number of people who are
obese by state beginning in 85 86 87
these are from the CDC website 88 89 90
91 you get a new category 92 93 94 95 96
97 98 99 2000 2001 it gets worse we're
kind of devolving now what can we do
about this well you know the diets that
we found that can reverse heart disease
and cancer is an Asian diet but the
people in Asia are starting to like we
are which is why they're starting to get
sick like we are so I've been working
with a lot of the big food companies
they can make it fun and sexy and hip
and crunching convenient to eat
healthier foods like I chair the
advisory boards and McDonald's in
PepsiCo and ConAgra and Safeway and soon
del Monte and they're finding that it's
good business the salads that you see at
McDonald's came from their work they're
gonna have an Asian salad at Pepsi
two-thirds of the revenue growth came
from their better foods and so if we can
do that then we can free up resources
for buying drugs that you really do need
for treating aids in HIV and malaria and
for preventing avian flu thank you